[MUSIC PLAYING]
FELIPE HOFFA: What's cooler
than a petabyte update?
Using that data to
improve your customer
business, your own business,
and even the world.
Hello, I'm Felipe Hoffa,
a Google Cloud developer
advocate.
And today, I'm in
Toronto, Canada
to meet my good
friends at Geotab.
They are the world's largest
provider of telematics,
tracking more than
1 million vehicles
on the seven continents.
And we're going to
meet Fiona Zhoa,
they're senior
data scientist, who
is going to show us how they
manage all of this data,
and even how you can use it to
understand how the world moves
around your house.
So let's get started.
Join me.
[WORDLESS SINGING]
We're here with Fiona
Zhao, senior data scientist
at Geotab.
Hi, Fiona.
FIONA ZHAO: Hi Felipe.
Very welcome to Toronto.
FELIPE HOFFA: I'm
so happy to be here.
So what does Geotab do?
FIONA ZHAO: So Geotab
is a telematics company.
We provide open platform
fleet management solutions
to businesses of all
kinds and all sizes.
So we're now having over
20,000 customers with us.
And those customers are
using the Geotab devices
to connect their vehicles
to their business,
so they can manage and
monitor the productivity,
the efficiency, the safety, and
the compliance of the drivers
and vehicles.
So we're now having
over 1 million devices
in running vehicles.
And from those vehicles,
we're collecting
over 2.1 billion
data sets per day.
FELIPE HOFFA: So what
does the device look like?
FIONA ZHAO: This is
Geotab GO device.
You can see the
small box, beautiful.
And there is a whole bunch of
magic happening inside the box,
collecting the data.
It's actually very easy install.
You can just plug and play.
FELIPE HOFFA: Even
I can plug it?
FIONA ZHAO: Yeah, we have
a harness already installed
on the truck, and the
only thing you need to do
is just plug the device in.
And after a few seconds,
you will hear beep.
[BEEP]
And now it starts to work.
FELIPE HOFFA: Oh, and I will
send data to your platform?
FIONA ZHAO: That's right.
FELIPE HOFFA: And how does this
data get into the platform?
FIONA ZHAO: Once the device
filters and calibrates
all the data, the
device itself will just
ensure that we are
sending the data that
carries the most information
with the least network cost.
So within, I believe it
was in several seconds,
the device data will go
into customers' databases
as well as our big data
environment for analysis.
FELIPE HOFFA: You
are a data scientist.
What's your job as
a data scientist?
FIONA ZHAO: One part of my job
is playing with those data.
I'm very happy to have
this large volume of data
to work with.
From them, I can create
a whole bunch of analysis
from different angles
to help internal users
to diagnose any possible
potential risks or flaws
or bugs.
And on the other hand, I also
work as the big data engineer.
So as an engineer, I need
to ensure that I design
and develop a reliable system.
FELIPE HOFFA: So you have
to create the pipelines,
store the data securely,
make the analysis
possible for everyone.
FIONA ZHAO: Yeah, and
as business grows,
I need to make sure
my application survive
for that long time,
and also grow,
can adapt to the future change.
FELIPE HOFFA: [INAUDIBLE]
you scale this platform,
as it grows more complex,
it collects more data,
more people are interested
in looking at it.
How long ago did you start?
FIONA ZHAO: I started
at Geotab in 2014.
FELIPE HOFFA: 2014,
like four years ago.
FIONA ZHAO: It's almost
four years, yeah.
FELIPE HOFFA: In 2014,
you chose BigQuery,
because you were able to
finally put all of these data
together in one place?
FIONA ZHAO: Yeah, we were
actually growing with BigQuery.
We tested with several
cloud providers.
And then we met with
Google BigQuery.
And we were very happy
with the performance
of the BigQuery API.
And also the capability of
BigQuery to run very big
queries based off
large scale of data.
We were quite happy with that,
and we stay with BigQuery.
FELIPE HOFFA: So how does
Geotab look like now?
FIONA ZHAO: So we're having 2.1
billion data points per day.
FELIPE HOFFA: Per day?
That's a lot of points.
FIONA ZHAO: Yeah,
when I joined in 2014,
there were around 300
million data per day.
So it's almost six
times of growth.
Geotab encouraged other teams
also to push their data,
to monitor their
work in BigQuery.
So right now, if you go
into the Geotab office,
you will be surrounded by
the dashboards and monitors
and where the whole company is
using data to monitor the work.
And we're a data-driven
company, actually.
FELIPE HOFFA: Can you show
me one of these dashboards?
FIONA ZHAO: Yes.
FELIPE HOFFA: Oh, cool.
FIONA ZHAO: As I
mentioned, we're
using these dashboards to see
how much data are coming in
and how quickly they're
coming in to BigQuery.
FELIPE HOFFA: Wait a second.
This dashboard is
a Google Slide?
FIONA ZHAO: Yes.
And it's a live dashboard.
It will be refreshed
every five minutes.
FELIPE HOFFA: Wow.
And what can you see here?
FIONA ZHAO: So from
the top, you can
see the total number of records
were in BigQuery right now is
over like one petabyte.
FELIPE HOFFA: More
than a petabyte?
FIONA ZHAO: Right.
And just for today, we got
over 2.1 billion roads already.
FELIPE HOFFA: Wow.
FIONA ZHAO: Compare it to
the records a year ago,
it's almost double.
And from these gauges, you
can see like per second,
we're having over
16,000 of GPS records.
And GPS records is less than
1/3 of our total data points.
FELIPE HOFFA: So this
device is not only
recording the GPS position.
FIONA ZHAO: So GPS
position is just 1/3 of it.
We also get all kinds of
the engine diagnostic data
from the vehicle
engine computer,
such as whether the drviver
has buckled his seatbelt,
and also the fuel
consumption, whether there
is any diagnostic
signal come out
from the computer,
all kinds of things,
and also the temperature.
FELIPE HOFFA: Also
temperature, so you're
tracking all of the
inside of the truck
thanks to your connection.
FIONA ZHAO: Yes, yeah.
FELIPE HOFFA: And then this
data come out from the device
into your platform,
into BigQuery?
FIONA ZHAO: Right
FELIPE HOFFA: And you're
tracking the time that it
takes to do all of this.
FIONA ZHAO: Yes.
So it's only seven seconds.
FELIPE HOFFA: Seven seconds
from device to BigQuery?
FIONA ZHAO: Right.
FELIPE HOFFA: And you have
a chart of the latency.
FIONA ZHAO: We're monitoring the
performance from our servers.
FELIPE HOFFA: So tell me
more about the slides.
That's really interesting.
FIONA ZHAO: Yeah, so
in the background,
we're running queries.
The data are in BigQuery.
We use the Jupyter
Notebook, which
is hosted by Google Data Lab.
We write queries
in the notebook,
produce all these
pictures and gauges.
We push up these guys
onto Google Cloud Storage.
And this Goodle Slide
can pull those files
from Google Cloud
storage and produce
this beautiful dashboard.
And jobs are setting in the
Google Slides can actual
refresh itself
every five minutes.
FELIPE HOFFA: That's a really
creative usage of Slides.
And then to orchestrate
all of these queries?
FIONA ZHAO: Oh, yes, because
queries have dependencies.
And we are using
the Apache Airflow
to orchestrate
those dependencies.
It's easy for us to
know, is is there
anything going on with
either of the dependencies?
FELIPE HOFFA: So BigQuery,
Slides, Airflow, what else?
FIONA ZHAO: Also, we're doing
machine learning projects.
Yeah, so we're using
TensorFlow as a framework.
We deploy our
applications and pipelines
on to a Google Dataflow, and
also [INAUDIBLE] clusters.
FELIPE HOFFA: Can you show me
one of your current projects?
FIONA ZHAO: Yes, it will
be very exciting to show
you one of our websites
we just launched.
It's called data.geotab.com.
Geotab sees the
value in big data.
And we want to show that
those values of big data
can be definitely
empower business.
Because we are not
just about telematics.
And telematics is not just
about GPS and the position.
We have the engine diagnostics
from the vehicle's engine
computer.
We have all kinds of other data
that comes from the auxiliiary.
So Geotab can also
provide an open platform
so business can use
those data and even
marry with other data
sources they have
to create creative
tools or reports
or any intelligence
out of those data.
So as a start point, we produce
a set of intelligence data
sets to help people, to
show people, OK, these
are the cool things that
we can do with the data.
FELIPE HOFFA: Aggregated data
within multiple customers.
FIONA ZHAO: Yes, within
multiple customers,
because we want to make sure
there's not any privacy issues
or confidentiality issues
that the users need
to worry about their data.
FELIPE HOFFA: And we can see
what's happening within cities.
FIONA ZHAO: That's right.
Either the government
or the people
can divert this data to do some
solutions for the smart city
even.
So for example, we
analyze what are the areas
with high risk of incidence.
FELIPE HOFFA: So you're
empowering smart cities,
governments, and drivers to see
where are the dangerous areas.
Can I see the website?
FIONA ZHAO: Yes, of course.
Let me show you.
Data.geotab.com,
within the website,
you can find the
data solutions, which
is the one that I
mentioned, that we
create some intelligence
data set as a starting point.
We have three categories
of those reports.
One is weather.
So you believe it or
not, like the vehicles
are actually collecting the
temperature and the barometer
pressure.
We can use this data to report
real-time and hyperlocal
temperatures.
FELIPE HOFFA: You're
getting hyper local weather
from all of these trucks and
vehicles all around the world?
FIONA ZHAO: Yeah,
we're at a granularity
which the regular weather
station might not be able to.
We also have the
[INAUDIBLE] infrastructure,
like the high risk driving
areas are one of them.
The third category is
the location analytics.
So for example, where are the
most popular gas stations,
and what are the
gas station types?
Maybe some of the gas stations
are exclusively for trucks.
Others are for passenger cars.
So we have those data and
can help users to locate
the proper gas station.
And also about the
parking, parking lots,
you can interestingly
say, like what
are the circle for parking.
FELIPE HOFFA: So
show me a little more
about the urban infrastructure,
what kind of data
you are collecting there.
FIONA ZHAO: Yeah,
there is actually
one data set that I produce,
which is the hazardous driving
area.
As I mentioned, we're
collecting accelerometer data.
So our [INAUDIBLE] engineers
calibrate and clean those data.
And we also have a whole
bunch of talented engineers
to do lots and lots of
experiments within a real car.
The purpose for that
is like, we need
to find a threshold
of the acceleration
so that we can
detect, OK, right now,
the driver is doing
harsh brake, or harsh
heading, or harsh cornering.
FELIPE HOFFA: And
now you're counting
the number of incidents?
FIONA ZHAO: Yes.
And also as we know that
the bigger the city is,
the more the incidents
will potentially be,
so we count the traffic flow
within that area and use
that to normalize
the incident count.
And then we come up
with a score, measure
what's the level of risk.
FELIPE HOFFA: Can we
take a look at the data?
FIONA ZHAO: Yes, yes.
So as a user, you can actually
use your email address
to register into this website.
And then within maybe
several minutes,
you will get a response email.
And just follow
the instructions,
so you can get into our
system to get the data.
FELIPE HOFFA: So anyone
that registers and agrees
to the license of this
data can take a look at it
and find what are the
most dangerous areas?
FIONA ZHAO: That's right.
FELIPE HOFFA: And how
would a query look?
FIONA ZHAO: In a white
paper on the website,
it has introduction to
what does this data set do
and how people can use
this data set to produce
a whole bunch of insights.
We listed several examples here.
As the first example,
we're looking
at the cities prone to hazardous
driving in Ontario, Canada.
FELIPE HOFFA: But I
live in California.
What if I wanted to
see what are the most
hazardous areas in California?
FIONA ZHAO: That
will be interesting.
So right now,
suppose I'm already
in the BigQuery data set.
FELIPE HOFFA: You
already have permission
to look at this table.
What are the results?
FIONA ZHAO: Yeah, within seven
seconds, we get the results.
And you can see.
I'll move the [INAUDIBLE] a bit.
The top city is Los Angeles.
FELIPE HOFFA: Because it's one
of the biggest cities, too.
FIONA ZHAO: Yes.
FELIPE HOFFA: Followed by
Long Beach, San Francisco,
San Diego, Oakland.
And if we wanted to
find the points that
were the most dangerous,
how would you do that?
FIONA ZHAO: The
points, OK, if you
want to look at Los Angeles,
we can search for Los Angeles.
FELIPE HOFFA: This query's
going over much data?
FIONA ZHAO: This data set
itself is not very big.
It's several megabytes of scale.
FELIPE HOFFA: So the size of
this data is not impressive.
These tables are
about 10 megabytes.
But what's impressive
is how much data
you use to produce it.
FIONA ZHAO: Right.
In order to produce
this small table,
we actually run analysis based
of at least one year of GPS
and one year of acceleration
and maybe other data
sets as we need.
So in the background,
there will be
like over 50
terabytes of data are
supporting this [INAUDIBLE].
FELIPE HOFFA: So you are able to
do everything within the query.
You can analyze
those 50 terabytes,
publish the new tables,
and make those tables
available for anyone
that wants to access it.
FIONA ZHAO: That's right.
So here are the columns.
We have the average latitude
and average longitude.
This is the average location
of the incidents happening
within a scope of the area.
And the size of area is around
150 meter by a 150 meter.
FELIPE HOFFA: 150 meter
squared, approximately.
FIONA ZHAO: Yes, and it
will also give the boundary
points of the square.
We give four points, the
four-point, and also the city,
county, if it's in the state,
and the state or province
name, country name, ISO country
code, the severity score,
the dimension.
We come up with
those measurements,
and the total
number of incidents.
FELIPE HOFFA: So
you have one count.
The first row has, in
this case, the area
with the maximum severity score.
FIONA ZHAO: Yes, that's right.
And we also break
down the incidents
by vehicle types, such as
like passenger car, truck,
on the road vehicle or off the
road vehicle, like tractors,
construction vehicles,
or electrical vehicles,
and even like
natural gas vehicles.
But in the other
columns, we are capturing
all kinds of vehicles data.
FELIPE HOFFA: Nice.
So you are able to see how
traffic conditions vary
depending on the type of--
FIONA ZHAO: Yes.
And people may be
also interested in,
OK, what type of vehicles are
creating the most incidents
on certain areas, so they
can help their analysis
based off more granular data.
FELIPE HOFFA: And
then on the first row,
you have the most [INAUDIBLE],,
and the second row,
we have one that had
had more incidents.
FIONA ZHAO: Yes.
FELIPE HOFFA: Yeah,
and if we wanted
to look at that
one, how would you--
FIONA ZHAO: You want to
look at the second one?
FELIPE HOFFA: Yeah.
FIONA ZHAO: Let's copy
the incident position
and open Google Maps.
FELIPE HOFFA: With
Street View, we
come down into the exact place.
FIONA ZHAO: So if we
zoom in a little bit,
it looks like around
distribution center
or construction area, which
like the driveway to the traffic
without any traffic
light control.
FELIPE HOFFA: Can you
show me a little more
about that, like what's
happening behind the scenes
to produce these tables?
FIONA ZHAO: As I
mentioned, we use
Notebook to write queries
and explore the results
and actually running
the query drops.
So first we need to
calculate the traffic flow
to normalize the data.
We need to count the incidents
from the raw accelerometer
data, comes from the device.
And also a very
important step is
we remove all the differential
information from those data.
And then we aggregate,
and we set up the jobs
running in the background
month by month and day
by day to collect the data
and run those reports.
FELIPE HOFFA: So
that's how you end up
with a query like this one?
FIONA ZHAO: Yeah, we're
able to actually leverage
the power from BigQuery.
We can write the
user-defined functions, UDFs,
to set a customized date
that we want to look at.
Because these queries
running as job,
we cannot manually set a date.
So we use UDF to get
what's today's date.
And with these parameters--
FELIPE HOFFA: Sub-queries?
FIONA ZHAO: Sub-queries, we
can make these queries look
beautiful and easy to manage.
FELIPE HOFFA: Then for each
geohash, for each hour,
you're getting the--
FIONA ZHAO: Yes, and
we're able to use
such as array
aggregation function,
so that we can easily
like a combination
and manipulate data easily.
FELIPE HOFFA: How much data
would this query go through?
FIONA ZHAO: This query,
so for one day of GPS,
we would probably have
over 15 terabytes.
FELIPE HOFFA: 15 terabytes.
FIONA ZHAO: Yes,
and these queries
can just finish within minutes.
FELIPE HOFFA: Within minutes.
FIONA ZHAO: Yeah,
it's really amazing.
FELIPE HOFFA: Yeah, it powers
everything you're doing,
so it's really good.
And that's how you're
able to handle complexity.
You put this within Airflow.
FIONA ZHAO: Yes, that's right.
There are lots of such queries
running in the background.
And we manage in a diagram,
dependence and diagram
in an Airflow so we
can monitor them.
FELIPE HOFFA: And what are
the plans for the future?
FIONA ZHAO: So definitely
more intelligence data sets
are going to come out.
FELIPE HOFFA: More
intelligent data, nice.
FIONA ZHAO: And
also, as you said,
these jobs are batch jobs.
They round analyst based
off of historical data.
And in the future,
right now, I'm
working on the
streaming analytics,
so we're hoping in
the near future,
we can really see the city
map in the real-time fashion.
Say for example, you're going to
say what's the traffic flow now
on the roads across the world.
FELIPE HOFFA: So you would
be able to produce streaming
analytics with Dataflow.
FIONA ZHAO: With Dataflow, yes,
[INAUDIBLE] and Kubernetes.
FELIPE HOFFA: And also, you're--
FIONA ZHAO: Yeah,
and also my coworkers
are working on a
machine learning project
to learn the driving
patterns of the fleet.
And once we know it,
we can help the users
to compare the fleets.
We can kind of
benchmark their work
to improve the productivity,
the efficiency, also the safety
and compliance.
FELIPE HOFFA: So with
machine learning,
you will be able to
extract more knowledge,
produce actionable advice,
improve the safety,
improve the productivity.
FIONA ZHAO: Yes, we
expand our insights.
Like we always did it.
We did it well.
But with machine
learning and big data,
we're going to have
the capability to do it
with more deeper insights.
FELIPE HOFFA: Yeah, Fiona,
I'm really impressed how
you went from like this
device to disparate databases,
to join all of this data in
one place, how the platform has
grown in the last four years.
It's impressive.
I'm so glad you wanted to share
this data and analysis with me.
FIONA ZHAO: Yeah, right.
Because Geotab is believing
in management by measurement,
and we want to help
other businesses
to do the same thing.
We make decisions
driven by data,
and we're going to help
people to do it, too.
FELIPE HOFFA: That's
really awesome.
So thank you for joining us.
And everyone, well, you can
follow @felipehoffa, and keep
tuned for more data videos.
Stay tuned.
[MUSIC PLAYING]